in this video the calmest test is explained in a simple way
we
go through together what the wax test is
what
the requirements are and how it is calculated finally i will show you how you can easily calculate the wilcox and
test online with
datatec and with it  i would
say let's start right
away the world ox test checks if there is a
difference between two dependent
samples so if you hate two dependent groups and want to check
is if there is a difference between
these two groups then you can use
a short test
say now  you are right hey the test for dependent samples does the same thing, it
also
checks whether there is a
difference between two
dependent samples that is completely
correct the wilksen test is the non-
parametric counterpart to the culprit is
for dependent samples the special
garbage cost test is that  your data
does not have to be normally distributed
verei  Simply put your data are
normally distributed are you using a
parametric test in the case of two
dependent samples is that the
culprit is for dependent samples are
your data not normally
distributed are you using a nonparametric
test in the case of two dependent
samples is that the wilksen test is
now  you can of course say
then i just always use the cloud
test then i don't even have to check
whether normal distribution shows why you
should always prefer the perpetrator if possible
i'll show you at the end of this
video a little reminder
what dependent samples were again
in dependent samples  if the
measured values ​​are in pairs the pairs
result, for example, from
repeated repetitions with the same people
so you have one and the same person who
you once before a certain event and
once after a certain one is the
walls then you have a dependent
random sample
what happens now  the difference
between the perpetrator for dependent samples
and in the wilksen test the
perpetrator is for dependent samples
checks whether there is a mean
value difference here we have a
dependent sample say we measured a value for each
person in the morning
and measured a value in the evening
now we can  calculate the difference from each value,
for example 45 -
34 is equal to 11 the culprit is for
dependent samples now checks whether these
differences deviate from 0 or not
please watch my
video on the dependent tt iss again for this
we will take a look at the short oil test  not the
differences but we form
ranks and then compare these ranks
with each other 3 is the
smallest value in terms of amount which gets the rank
14 is the second smallest value which
gets the rank
26 gets the rank third and eleven
gets the rank fourth all
positive values ​​we add a
plus to all negative values ​​-
but none  gst we'll go
through that again with an example now
but first to the
requirements and the hypotheses at the wilksen fest
only two dependent
random samples with at least original
scaled characteristics
must be available the variables do not have to fulfill a distribution curve working is
to be noted
that the distribution form  the
differences between the two slopes
should be approximately symmetrical.
the null hypothesis in the boxing test is
that there is no
difference in the central trend
between the two groups in the population,
hence that there is no difference
between the two dependent
groups. the alternative hypothesis is that
there is a
difference in central tendency in the population
so both depend groups are
different so and now
we finally come to the simple example
let's say you have the reaction time of
a small group of people once
in the morning and once in the evening g  and
want to know if there is a difference
between morning and evening for this
you measured the reaction times of seven
people in the morning and in the evening the
measured values ​​are always in
pairs and we therefore have a
dependent random sample now you can tell
the difference between morning and evening
calculate if the difference were normally
distributed you would use a test for
dependent samples if this
is not the case a wilksen test
let's just say the data are
not normally distributed and we have to
calculate a path that is ox-proof for this
we first have to see the ranks we'll see
what  is the smallest value in terms of amount
that is - 2 which then gets the rank
number one what is the second smallest
value that is 3 which then gets the rank
number two and so on and so forth until
we all have been assigned a rank
now let's see which ones
differences positive and which
ones are negative for the negative ones we write each other
just add - now we can
add up the positive ranks
and add up the negative ranks
from the positive ones come out 7 + 2
+3
+46 it was equal to 22 is the
negative rain comes out five plus
one which is live sex when  there is no
difference between morning and
evening the positive and
negative ranks should be about the same the
new hypothesis is that both rank
totals are the same but how do i check
that now
we already have the total of the
last rank here we can use the test
statistics  how to calculate it
simply results from the minimum value of t plus
and - in our case the smaller
value of 22 and sex therefore this
statistic is like in our case 6
now we can calculate the value for tbz www
which we would expect if
it  there would be no difference between morning
and evening in this
case an expected value of 14 would
come out therefore if there is no
difference between mo  mornings and
evenings we would actually expect a value
for the plus and t minus of 14
and that would mean 14
then we can then
calculate the standard deviation which
results from this fairly
complicated formula if we have all
that  can we now
calculate the set value the time value is found by
calculating and dividing that by the
standard deviation so we
compare the value you
would expect if there is no difference
to the value that actually
occurred note that if there is more
than 25  cases there are more than 25 pairs
normal distribution is assumed in this
case we can then calculate z with this formula
if there are less than 25
values ​​then the critical type is
read from a table with the critical ones so in our case
we actually hear the table
use and now I'll show you
how to do the wilksen test easily
o  online and then
we'll go into why you
should always prefer the dependent perpetrator to
the probably short test if possible
to calculate the contest online
simply go to date up de the link
can be found in the video description and
copy your own data  here in
this table
you then click on this tag
under this tag a lot of
hypotheses tests are bundled and depending on
which variables you like
now the correct hypotheses test is
suggested here now you can see
the names of the variables that you up
here in  if you copy the table
in the morning and evening how
is it datatec automatically recognizes that
it is a dependent random sample
and calculates the dependent
offender we don't want to calculate an offender
but the wilksen test so
we just click on it now
calculates the date for us  up automatically the
wilksen test we can here the
negative  n and read the positive things
and here we can read the time value
and the ph value if you don't
know exactly how that is interpreted
just look at the summary
the morning group has
lower values ​​is called the working group
once costs peres showed that this
the difference was not statistically
significant, the p value is 03 12
so we can
not reject the null hypothesis based on this data and
therefore assume that there is
no difference between morning and evening
and now, as promised, we come
to the point why you always
parametric tests so, for example,
the perpetrator should prefer the non-parametric tests if possible,
we said that the volcanic test has
fewer requirements than the
perpetrator is now, of course, the question
can arise why do I use parametric tests
like the
parametric test at all  are generally
test stronger than non-parametric  e
tests what does that mean we say you have
formulated your 0 hypothesis for
example the ability to react is the
same in the morning and in the evening whether the new
hypothesis is rejected or not
depends, among other things, on the difference in
the ability to react and on the
sample size in a
parametric test ranges in the  rule out
a small difference or a
smaller sample to reject the null
hypothesis and both are of
course practical,
so if possible always use
parametric tests because they
are stronger if you
would like to read them accordingly, we would like to have a
look at our statistics book again  made
easy with the e-book you understand
the basics of statistics with many graphics and simple texts
if you like
just have a look the link is
in the video description i hope
you liked the video and see
you next time bye